[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports pre-game
picks the only show in the world with
you the people at home get to win free
cash prizes by simply predicting a
random [ __ ] that occurs in the nba
pregame
tonight we got a lot of money to give
away we got a lot of stuff curry
live from golden state so get ready get
your popcorn ready
and let's get to these pics baby
lois what's poppin dog when all that
famous love something in the building
let's get it boom i told you how crazy
is that wait is that a three let's see
that's a three
that's a three step curry wow
my name is i told y'all welcome to
pregame picks let's get it
hey we back another episode of pregame
picks as always i'm your host pierre aka
p with the plug and i'm joined by my
brother from another
famous lost was popping brody
yeah we are back in business what it do
brother what it do we back
the boys are back in town and we got my
boy dan back it's gonna be a nice
episode shout out to my boy ben too but
lois just to start us off
you and all the people at home i need to
know y'all answers for this especially
uses you to steph curry fanatic
will steph curry finish his career in
golden state
that's the question we're leading the
show with i need your thoughts
immediately talk to me first of all i'm
31 years old so don't ever say i'm
another grown man
fanatic so don't ever say that do i
think
so i'm sorry yes dude i think he can
play basketball yes look at the
banisters look at the banisters that was
me
i did that i did that y'all i did that
hey but yes steph steph he better finish
there
because i don't feel like wearing
another color
no i i i hear you too as well a lot of
people are asking this
or having this conversation because but
but i'm calling lebron and was
recruiting him
who don't follow you yeah but the
warriors who don't know
i really don't know it's it's something
it's they got something against me so
i don't know we i wouldn't trip if we
did dip on them
hey sister since the warriors don't
follow you
and so the people don't know i'm
bullshitting
i'm on instagram right now
i got the golden state warriors
instagram page on my phone right there
and i i'm blocking them i'm blocking
them until they follow you don't block a
p
p don't block the gold state warriors
hey golden state warriors y'all are
blocked on instagram by pee wee the plug
hoh until y'all follow my boy famous
lois i
y'all might not give a damn but we're
gonna start something we're gonna start
a petition for y'all to follow my boy
famous lois because
if anybody deserving is him lois we gon
we gonna we gonna start this campaign
brody you just boxed them i just blocked
them too pete
i blocked them too hey hey don't
take it a step further i'ma i'm gonna go
i'm on twitter right now at golden state
warriors
follow at famous lost
hashtag and support
i love it in all caps i love everybody
in the comments
or watching at home go do the same thing
on twitter
hashtag follow lost at the golden state
warriors
all capital letters with the hashtag
follow those and we're gonna get this
train rolling so my boy can get
followers
hornets blazers kings uh
uh memphis uh cliffords
a few motifs they follow me i'm like
dang my team don't follow me all right
pete ball
hey go back uh production can we get a
can we get another clip at ball boy let
me see what lo's talking about
because you know i got some b i got some
bing bing 202
which one the one with the tats the one
with the tattoo the one with the
collared shirt
you only want to see the one with the
tasks i was talking about the other one
the one with the tabs
are small the one with the tablets the
one
hey the one the one with the tats to
never pick up a basketball again if you
step on the court of me i promise you
that
and the one the one in the middle he
holding towers for a reason
he hold towels for a reason ain't never
healed no group of towers like that
and can we get i want to get in front of
you look at you dribbling that
basketball
oh yeah oh yeah his ass is grass if he
steps to me
and then homie homie got a collared
shirt for a reason
come on now yeah come on now you might
you must know who it is but anyway
steph curry uh i got steph curry
finishing finishing his career
with uh with the golden state war it
don't make sense for curry to leave why
would he leave
he made everything there the warriors
are the warriors because steph curry so
it don't even make sense for him to
leave i hate that we even talking about
that
like i think brian windhorst reported
that lebron was recruiting him
you can't recruit steph curry that's
disrespectful to steph why would steph
jump on brian [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying yeah no that
ain't yeah no oh i'm not tripping
talk to me though so i'm not tripping no
that's not
hey bro i would never let that happen
i would never why is everybody bald
right now i'm getting nervous
i would never let that happen
except for my boy that got my boy here
get your buddy
everybody look steph
steph with the warriors they should they
got to give himself whatever
he wants whatever steph won't he get to
keep him there for the rest of his life
i'm in the comments right now lois and
shout out my boy fresh prince he says
steph won't leave he can't leave his
splash roll like that i think that's a
great point you can't leave a splash bro
hey fresh prince because i'm a fan of
that comment so much and i think that's
facts
we gonna send you home with some money
congratulations to fresh prince he won
200
already by just getting giving off a
comment that we like it's that simple
at pre-game picks we're giving away
money for no reason so stay tuned and
get you some money you agree with this
agreeing with her because i agree with
you boy
yeah and plus and plus it always helps
when you agree
with me and lois um so there you go we
giving money away just that simple
and hey i want to go back to the dj lo
so you know where this dj is
before we get to the next part is
getting down he really did
he really is getting that right now he
turned up i was gonna say he got the
best
[Laughter]
did the dj deserve a big bean go
break him down when you like that no
when you're like that you don't you
don't deserve to get big man come on man
he living
we gotta award him
hey real quick sad bet i bet you won't
know who jersey that is he wearing
i bet you don't know who jerry said it
is he wearing if you get it right i'll
do 25 uh jumping jacks right now
who jersey he wearing steph yep
you owe me 25 jumper jacks right now
that's number eight that's monte ellis
man come on now
while while lose is doing his 25 jumping
jacks we're gonna move on to the next
prompt i want y'all in the comments to
let us know what y'all thinking
will steph make seven shots in the world
during his pregame warm up
yes or no lose
give the people some guidance with your
answer is steph gonna make seven shots
in a row doing this warm up
no oh look at big swallow look at big
sword no y'all got frank thomas
[ __ ] doing security now strongest
hair
look at him strong his
oh hair gosh that's big hurt frank
thomas
all my baseball fans y'all know the big
hurt south side chicago yes sir
he focuses hell first shot ain't nobody
right on that
court first sign of trouble he gonna
take off
so you got steph making seven in a row
no i don't gotta make a seven in a row
you don't get steph curry making seven
shots in a row doing one more
nah oh hell naw
hey listen this i got steph curry making
seven shots in a row we talking about
the greatest shooter ever
this is warm-ups he bout to get in this
bag i feel like this is a big game for
tonight
all y'all at home if you want some money
go with me
i lost usually you know what he's
talking about but not today
steph curry will hit seven shots he's
gonna start three and it's gonna be
six it's gonna be oh
i'm going seven man he gonna start off
with three or four layups that's a
that's a give right there
there's a gift everybody i know that's
what i know but steph's so
steph's so goofy uh two of the layups
gonna be to the ceiling
hey shout out to curl215 that means
curling 2-1-5 he's in philly shout out
to philly gilly the kid now
uh he said seven shots too easy to step
make it a little harder
so shout out my boy curl he's gonna
agree he said the next one
hydra hydranium that's a crazy name yes
i'll take a
step further say he makes double digits
in a row wow that's a little bit too
much yeah
i might have to yeah that that that's
that's that's what he mean yes
yes three points seven threes in a row
he's saying yes and he's gonna have a
streak of three so yeah
um okay yes steph is making seven my boy
hi
my boy i know why y'all winning
because they know i know what the hell
i'm talking about we got the bucks on
the court
what the what is brook lopez hey rewind
it what is brook lopez doing
can we rewind that real quick lo
tell me what the hell was this i hope we
can be able to get a rewind
i want to know what uh yeah i almost
curse
i almost cursed my tv out what what what
is this
he'll give you he'll give you watch him
watch his
watch his big ass what is he doing you
gonna see him
look at him what the [ __ ] is that hey yo
i love it
i love it he tried to throw that [ __ ]
from a coach's a coach's perspective
i'd be i'd be extremely mad if he came
down on an ankle the wrong way
by trying to block his own teammate's
shot hey dude we got steph did we got
steph counter up did he make a layup
did he make a layup please let me know
if he made a left he took no layup yeah
you think he gonna be the first to make
a layup yeah
yeah he made a layup like i said he made
the layup
okay that's one in a row baby we're
going seven in a row
i'm glad i'm glad i got rid of the
braves but steph had them braves won't
make it i was cheating
i was i had right right hand to god i
was just about to ask you about my man's
hair
if you feeling that i i know you would
i you know what i'm saying i ain't too
fond of the braids either that's two in
a row already
just five more stuff let's make this
easy let's get straight to the point i
feel like giving
giving away all money today we wasting
time
hey girls um shaking up with raps and
[ __ ] so late
girl hair be so late every game
right here beside the other rail the
other road
yeah oh girl right there oh the girl oh
girl i saw the ponytail
i saw it from the back jesus christ come
on look at you you thirsty
you thirsty i'm committed well i'm
committed to a whole
boy i'm committed and unfaithful as hell
boy black men don't cheat
hey i hope not but you didn't show us
here thirsty
well i'm committed i'm talking about the
a lady boy you hear me
i said oh girl from arizona i said
hey speaking speaking of committed my
girl just texts me right now so i'm
going to see what you talk about
during the show because that's on the
line but uh
that's not a lot that's not a lie steph
curry's still at two
or is it steph curry man okay steph
curry missed he he has zero
he has zero he has zero
[Applause]
hey i hate when you write lois i ain't
gonna lie so i'm hoping my mans get on
track
everybody hate when all right don't you
see on twitter don't just see on twitter
how they talking about me everybody hate
when i'm right
hey i hear you bro i got distracted
because he just gave
he gave us a little bing [ __ ] he gave us
a little big beat right
say that uh say that clip for later uh
production i want to bring that back up
so those can give us a live b
hey did you see babies like this
what the hell did you just see the
babies
did you see baseball when he water while
he do the bull like that shoes
lois i do not watch nothing that
uh kent bayes moore is doing sir i'm
gonna just be streaming
damien too
no he didn't i would have seen it bro i
would have seen
it it's no way in here remember when
steve was home and you didn't tell me
you remember
so i knew when the season came back
around and
after all this don't happen i said damn
all right i see i see
i said damn i know i ain't gonna get a
chance for him to play in him cause too
much time that went by
hey um you ever been to the arena
you ever been to the arena yeah
is it decent i'm talking with this new
one not the old one not the oracle
oh no no no no no oh no no no no they
had a new one no
yeah i i never been to the oracle either
you living up you living your best life
you know what i'm saying you don't be
looking out for the homies but you know
it's understandable everybody
nah a giver like i actually did work
with them
some people are selfish listen i did
work with them and
something happened and got got into it
with the people and something like that
some boo
some little bs and i swear that's
probably why they don't follow me
you gotta who the hell are you getting
in tour with how you getting towards
somebody
how the hell somebody i think it was
like securities like security was
telling me
security was telling me i couldn't walk
somewhere i'm like
bro i mean i'm i'm literally working
here what i'm like
filming right now just i'm like i have
passes and everything but
i don't know you know how people
overusing their power he back at zero
too i told you
hey i didn't want to say nothing but
yeah he back at zero that's one
shout out to my boy he says
what's his name on youtube splash
yeah there we go catch up don't play
games fomo stuff give me fomo
give me fomo hey lois the warriors are
playing the bucks tonight
so i gotta ask you how you feel about
the band
they just got how you feel about that
bag through holiday just got
i ain't really been watching drew dale
but the drew that i know hey steph just
missed
um but the truth that i know the drew i
know
he deserved that bag but i haven't been
watching them with the box like that
iris hey you know what i respect that
answer bro
i respect that answer a lot of people be
[ __ ]
the pelicans drew yeah
oh no i'll never forget when he locked
up
what was that damon cj heman rondo when
the pelicans had boogie but boogie got
hurt
yeah come on bro come on bro come on bro
but dude
but but do you think that's right do you
do you think the bucks are legit now
cause now they got giannis locked up
they got drew locked up and they got
chris locked up
but that ain't enough
i've never been more mad when steph
makes a shot
that's not enough that's four that's
four we need three i know
i've never said damn when steph makes
them lock in
five [ __ ] hey hey remember when i said
six y'all remember i said six
nobody said six we might say give me two
more give me two more
yeah i never been more happy for my boy
to miss but i am today
steph are you are you freaking [ __ ]
joe
up are you [ __ ] me
hey hey hey
i want to make a sad bed with you real
quick cause i just saw a funky ass jump
shot
nothing [ __ ] about nobody because these
are all pros
but if we could get a if we well steph
just he back at three so let me relax
before i get this side bet off with it
real quick
real quick
he heat up real quick hey i'm gonna pull
these out to help them i'm gonna pull
these out to help her
put him back up he just missed
[Applause]
pull them back up what you know about
these what you know about these sir
oh what's that that's them some new ones
are for old ones
these are all the [ __ ] i don't i got my
own i got my own
well this is that ain't what you want to
do oh hold on right back
two seconds champ championship edition
championship edition baby we got the
for the people at home we got the gold
tips to the camera p
and such not you know it look gold
some gold championship additionally make
sure it's in the camera
[Laughter]
yeah i'm saying they still a little
white i ain't warm in years
we back at two and we back at two i pour
the shoes out and i'm stuffed making
them
i pour the shoes out and i'm still
making them come on stuff don't let me
down
matter of fact i'm gonna put them on i'm
gonna put them on and i know the people
at least report
probably piss cause i'm showing some
under armour
please he will not he goofing too much
lito shut up
for you i'm gonna make sure leto don't
get no money on purpose protect for
going against my comment i don't
i don't like that leader no i'm just
joking you know how you're not going
with my boy i am going with my boy
that is my boy hey fresh prince hey
something together where fresh prince
can win some money i want to cheat for
fresh prince he agrees with everything
i'm saying so let's rig
this system and make sure he wins some
money
first place hit me up on twitter i'mma
hook you
up bro hey what's up curry sevens
okay the curry sevens
with the big 30 at the bottom and at 32
and at 32.
hey but oh
i can see her oh why you do that ball
like that i don't know what
i don't
they real they do curry savage they real
shoes
i got [ __ ] on that for you i have my own
collab with steph and under armour
come on stop [ __ ] then this where my
parrot what my pair at the end
out i was only able to send them to 40
influencers
and 40 family members 40 influencers and
40 family members
and in chicago at the all-star game in
chicago
people bought them
that that's crazy because i was at the
all-star game in chicago because i'm
from chicago
it was it was the whole event was that
underground
i didn't get i didn't get up here that's
some [ __ ] it was some [ __ ] it
was 300
it was it was 300 pair
i was who i am now there too i had my
credentials and everything as well so it
wasn't like the old pierre before i was
anything
so that's the [ __ ] i'm gonna need a
pair under arm
but i want you to see steph step out to
get to seven in a row just because it is
i'm wearing a man i just put mine on my
feet
why did you why'd you look like me
hey you got to wear these stuff you
don't hey
stop
you know you hate when i pull up who you
do look like put some lotion on too boy
unacceptable y'all y'all ignore pete
ignore what he's saying
ignore what he's saying and steph
post this right here so steph can see he
ain't what it is yet
and i can i can i can smell them they i
smell
50. put some damn lotion on
and steph curry shoot the damn
basketball
for the silly ass workouts working out
your hips and all that [ __ ]
then you yellow go shoot that's why
there it is
damn oh he got he got caught
y'all light skin boys look at y'all
light skinned boys
look at y'all biting somebody saying we
win the shoes if you don't win
well apparently lo said he can't hook
none of us up
but i'll give you my shoes no they
stopped making them
they stopped making them you had to be
an all-star buy them it was 300 pesos
i want i want the ones in your damn hand
how about that no you can't fit you
can't fit these you can't fit these
right here
what size is those
shout out to bleacher report for letting
us be ourselves too what size is those
ain't even really
common english but what what size is
those issues
in english us you wear size six
hey that's four in a row i'm joking
that's a size nine nine
that's four for steph i've seen it i
tried to ignore it he missed that he
missed the layout do not count
goofy as hell that don't [ __ ] goofy
i told
can the bucks win can the bucks win a
championship bro can the bus win the
championship they can all they know
everybody can yo no you're a
hell no you're a damn fool no hell yeah
hey okay one minute left if you win with
famous lows
you're about to win some moolah let's
see
we got one minute left under a minute
left steph curry's shaking hands and
sitting down and [ __ ] so i'm gonna
i'ma tee up the next prompt will the
warrior's last shot be a dunk or a jump
shot
step uh loose is there gonna be a jump
shot or whatever
will the last shot be a dunk or a layup
jump shot a layup jump shot jump shot
jump shot jump shot
jump you don't win anytime just so you
know just so you know when a clock hits
zero
this [ __ ] i'm going off to the
locker room got it hey get those damn
shoes out my face
i told you you see these i still
get them shits out of my face i'm
putting back on my uggs that was a big
ass disappointment i like to give people
money
hopefully a lot of y'all listen to lois
we died as soon as it hits zero dunk or
jumper
it's gonna be a jumper shot a jumper
jumper nobody's sleeping
bingo bingo jumper nope
do not [ __ ] count because he was out
yeah
so can we please pull up the winners
from the first
prompt which was steph curry seven jump
shots in a row i was wrong
lois was right i hate you you wasn't
wrong you wasn't wrong you just
you wasn't wrong don't ever say he
wasn't you was wrong you just weren't
right
[Music]
damn you just weren't looking at them
look at them okay
so there's five winners that went with
lost and it'll be taking 500
home tonight we got jb loading we got
evan
in uh 21. make sure y'all check y'all
bleacher report accounts and dm so you
can get that paper
the final shot boom that was a jump shot
boom that last one it was not drama
draymond
i'm convinced draymond got an earpiece
into some [ __ ] he tried to he tried to
sabotage
his must be like a a point point one two
late or something like that draymond
point one earlier draymond went like he
went at the buzzer
i'm awesome he's trying to get a buzzer
beater
oh okay but i love it i love it i love
it i love it we want somebody
so much ain't no ain't nobody nobody
nobody show no love to my tweet either
my tweet got one like saying
go follow you that's some that the one
that that was to the warriors to say uh
follow famously i'll tell you that's
some hate
my tweets maybe some hate my tweets dude
do 250 per tweet so that's some bullet
should be all right hey don't do not use
my name you know tweet boy
they hate him hey look at yourself we
going to see you
next week hey we got look at that big
hurt we got to get some
we got to get some more money away bro
next week
i love y'all we're going to be back next
week i love y'all i love y'all i love
y'all love y'all one time two times
three times
we're back y'all shout out to my winners
tonight let's go
[Music]
[Music]
all right p all right gang
aye my boy
[Applause]
yep
you